in a 4-3 decision the Colorado Supreme
Court has officially kicked Donald Trump
off the presidential primary ballot
because an eccentric and a horn hat and
some Midwestern Granny's got a police
guided tour of the US capital on January
6th the worst day in the history of this
already
Republic uh the court has decided that
President Trump LED an Insurrection
against the United States and may
therefore be disqualified from Office
the legal reasoning is as you might
imagine rather weak
the court argued that if it didn't take
the unprecedented action of
exercising listen to this of exercising
an anti-confederate
provision of a Civil War era
constitutional amendment to impede a
presidential candidate from running for
office
then if it didn't do that it would
thereby forfeit any right to prevent
anyone from running for president you
have a 20s something foreign National
who shows up in America the court unless
it enforces this provision against Trump
would not be able to stop that random
young Foreigner from running for
president I am not joking that is
actually in the Court's writing here the
Court's reasoning
argues that if it does not radically
reinterpret this 150-year-old
constitutional provision to stop a
popular former president from seeking a
second term than all of the actual
constitutional requirements for the
presidency 35 years old natural born
citizen all of those somehow would go
out the window too I I'm not even sure
how to engage with this kind of legal
argument it is so absurd on its face but
the legal reasoning is not actually as
absurd as the political reasoning
brought to you by The self-appointed
Defenders of democracy who now hold that
the only way to defend democracy is to
prohibit people from voting for the
popular candidate I'm Michael nlls this
is the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show more
allegations of plagiarism against the
Harvard president and when I say
allegations I mean just proof because
we're talking about actual written
evidence that we see uh Harvard
president plagiarizing so much that she
actually plagiarized the
acknowledgements of one of her books she
she plagiarized to thank you in addition
to all the scholarship we'll get to that
in a second first
though do you remember when way back in
the year 2000 it was an attack on
Democracy that the Supreme Court decided
that
election but now that the Supreme Court
of Colorado is attempting to decide the
election that is saving democracy isn't
that a little strange I think it was
Edmund smirk who first pointed that out
to me on Twitter I there doesn't seem to
be much logic
here we are being told that this
decision specifically is a great defense
of
democracy it's just yet another reminder
for the handful of people out there who
haven't gotten the message yet that when
the libs say democracy they don't really
mean democracy because democracy just
means whatever 50% plus one of the
people vote for that's democracy
democracy is popular
rule
sometimes the people vote for Liberal
stuff sometimes the people vote for
anti-liberal
stuff what the libs do is they conflate
liberalism and democracy but democracy
is not necessarily liberal when the
Hungarian people elect Victor Orban that
that's not liberal and what happens what
happens is all the libs around the world
say it's an attack on Democracy
democracy no longer exists in Hungary
what are you talking about Orban is
extremely popular and most people voted
for him or voted for his party and made
him prime
minister he's he's very popular he is an
expression of democracy he's not liberal
naib buk the leader in El Salvador is
not liberal very popular not liberal
Maloney when she got elected in Italy
very popular she did not run on a
liberal
platform the brexit in the UK very
popular very Democratic much democracy
very popular not liberal and same goes
for Trump when liberalism and democracy
come into conflict the libs will always
go with liberalism and that's fine
that's their prerogative but what's so
deceptive what's so dishonest is they
say they're doing it in the name of
democracy they hate democracy they only
like democracy when it's convenient for
them when it exalts liberalism and
there's a lesson here for conservatives
by the way the libs recognize that
substantive Goods matter at least as
much actually more than procedural norms
so democracy is the procedural Norm
liberalism is the substantive good in
their minds I think it's a substantive
bad but that that that's the difference
right you use democracy as the
instrument to get
liberalism and the Liberals are saying
well the goods are more important than
the
means conservatives we get so confused
we say there there are conservatives out
there who say well look we have to
enshrine a Satan statue in the Iowa
state capital because of the procedural
Norm of some misinterpretation of
religious freedom we have to look I know
Satan's bad and everything but it's much
more important to have
procedure I don't care what you say but
I'll defend to the death your right to
say it for some reason I don't know why
I don't I will not defend to to the
death the right of satanists to worship
Satan I won't I won't defend it at all
actually I don't I certainly won't give
my life for it that's crazy no because
substantive Goods matter the kind of
society that we have the norms and
standards According to which we live
actually matter much more than the the
mere procedure of how we get those
things now speaking of the rule of law
Governor Abbott down in Texas has just
signed a groundbreaking law really big
deal um it's going to make it a crime to
illegally enter the state of Texas wait
what that was the headline there was a
headline all over the place yesterday
Governor Abbott signs groundbreaking new
law to
criminalize entering Texas illegally um
does isn't that a bit redundant is it a
double negative is it now legal to enter
Texas illegally what does that mean well
what it really means is it's of course
it's illegal to enter illegally but
that's a federal law and Joe Biden's not
going to enforce Federal immigration law
but until now Texas has basically had
its hands tied to enforce the law on its
own border so now there is a state law
that will allow the state of Texas to
enforce Federal immigration law because
the feds don't actually want to do
it it's good good on abbit unfortunately
I don't think it kicks in right away and
who knows if it's going to be enforced
but good on him I mean I like the idea
in theory
but at a deeper level how pathetic is
that how pathetic is it that our country
has decayed to such a point that we now
need to pass laws to make crimes illegal
crimes that are already crimes on the
books crimes that are already defined by
their illegality we call it illegal
immigration entering illegally and we
need to pass in law to say it's extra
double illegal now so now we can
actually enforce the law it it's just
proof the fact that this law has to be
passed in Texas is proof that we no
longer have a serious functioning rule
of law in this
country if you if you can no longer
trust that your laws will be enforced
even your most basic
laws then
then what's the point of the second law
what are we going to do next pass a
third law okay now it's extra super
double triple illegal to enter Texas so
come on you you're going to enforce it
this time right no probably
not because
because a system of law only has power
if it is credible a system of law only
has power if it is actually enforced so
if the law is not enforced then doesn't
matter pass as many extra new laws as
you
want the the entire system has lost its
credibility so what what the Texans are
counting on here is that well there's
still some credibility at the state
level even if there's not at the federal
level okay I hope so but we're not going
to we're not going to last very long if
our system of laws has no credibility
speaking of crimes story that you're not
seeing reported very many
places a former family vlogger named
Ruby Frank just pled guilty to four
felony counts of second degree
aggravated child abuse according to
video footage of the hearing that was
uploaded to YouTube uh this I don't
follow family vloggers I don't really
follow vloggers of any sort uh but this
is a Utah mother of six and she has 2.3
million YouTube followers it's that's a
big YouTube channel and had a a Family
Channel called Eight passengers and I
guess what she did was she would just
film her family and all of her little
kids and she's now been
charged with six counts of felony child
abuse and pled guilty to
four uh her her business partner jod
hilderbrand was arrested in August after
cops found one of Frank's children with
open wounds after running away from the
business partner's home another kid was
found malnourished just really terrible
stuff glad that this woman is uh going
to see some justice and that the kids
are going to have some
justice at a deeper level though
all family vlogging is child abuse as
far as I'm concerned it's
not you're not always beating the kids
or mal nourishing them but it's all
really bad I'm not I'm not in any way
surprised by this story when I see
people exploiting their kids for content
on the internet I
think bad
parenting stop it immediately don't do
it even people who aren't making money
on it even people who who are just
farming likes who just get a A Rush of
excitement when they see people liking
their pictures and then they they
exploit their children to get all these
likes don't do
it your job as a parent is to protect
your children and part of protecting
your children means not uploading 10,000
pictures of them to the internet where a
bunch of who knows who are going to look
at them are going to watch them it's
going to expose them to some degree of
notoriety and fame it might it might
make them look foolish it might it might
you might might be uh deriving your
clicks out of mocking them or or
exploiting your anxieties and your your
frustration with your children and it's
just bad what good can possibly come of
that it is a problem that we've been
talking about for weeks now in all sorts
of different areas we were talking about
surrogacy a couple of weeks ago about
how the problem with surrogacy is that
it commoditized human beings we
shouldn't treat human beings as means to
an end we shouldn't treat human beings
as objects for our enjoyment or our
benefit we should treat human beings as
ends in themselves not to be
commoditized not to be turned into uh
vessels for rent not to be turned into
products to be purchased like you see in
the case of ibf and surrogacy not to be
turned into media objects to exploit for
clicks or likes or money it's just wrong
these are your
kids don't do it it's bad
that the difference between this woman
who just pled guilty to Mal nourishing
and beating her kids or whatever the
charges were four felony counts the
difference between her and every other
family vlogger blogger posting a million
pictures of your kids for all the world
to see is a is a difference of degree it
is not a difference in kind so if you're
doing it cut it out okay that is some
really golden advice that I am giving
you right now and when you want actual
physical gold you got to check out Birch
gold right now text nolles to 9898 98
this Christmas season you can diversify
your savings into physical precious
medals while stockpiling free silver in
your home safe do not miss out on Birch
gold group's most popular special of the
year now through December 22nd for every
$55,000 you spend with Birch gold they
will send you a 1 o Silver Eagle Coin
for free text nolles kwes to 98 9898 to
claim your eligibility now you can
purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch Gold's precious metal Specialists
help you convert an existing Ira of 401k
into a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no
money out of pocket and they will send
you free silver for every five grand you
purchase keep it for yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuffer this year that's a very good
stocking stuffer just text keyword
nolles to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with a
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold Birch gold text nolles kwes to
98 9898 claim your eligibility for free
silver un qualifying purchases before
December 22nd that is nolles kwes to 998
9898 speaking of
Courts you know Sandra de o Conor died
do you know this this was I I guess
while I was away when I was pursuing my
dream of becoming a professional sitar
player in India if only I had brought my
sitar it would have worked out I think I
think it was while I was away maybe it
was right before I left but in any case
no one has talked about it you remember
when Ruth Bader Ginsburg died and it was
all we heard about for months well we we
heard about it before she died everyone
was waiting for her to die preparing all
of the eulogies and the parades and the
biopics and the
everything and then she died and then it
was another two months of morning and
then Sandra de oconor dies no one even
thinks about most people don't even know
who she
is everyone REM MERS Ruth Bader Ginsburg
you know the first woman on the Supreme
Court but no one remembers Sandra de o
Conor the actual first woman on the
Supreme Court the way that history has
been revised and the way that the
narrative has been formed it is as
though Ruth Bader Ginsburg the
Trailblazer the woman who paved a path
for all of us but especially for women
it is as though she were the first woman
on the Supreme Court appointed by Bill
Clinton that wonderful liberal president
but that's not what happened the first
woman on the court was Sandra Deo Conor
who was at least vaguely conservative
Who was appointed by Ronald
Reagan but that doesn't work with the
narrative it doesn't fit I'm not even
the biggest fan of Sandra de o Conor's
Juris Prudence but it seems rather
unfair that she's written out of history
but of course of course she was going to
be written out of the
story the story is already written
okay conservatives are evil Liberals are
good conservatives are oppressing the
masses Liberals are liberating
people that is why when a conservative
wins an election something had to be
wrong with the election even if it was
the cleanest election ever in history
something had to be wrong the the people
were hypnotized into a false
consciousness the fraud happened at the
level of the of the Soul actually the
the the the deception that was
perpetrated by the conservatives was so
subtle no one even saw it
happening but it had to be wrong the
Liberals have to win the
elections popularly because they are the
ones liberating people and so if the
people don't know their own good it's
because of the conservatives tricked
them has to be the case Donald Trump had
to lead an Insurrection never mind that
he told people don't don't go into the
capital go home be peaceful don't be
violent don't be nice he had to do it
the horn hat guy had to be an evil
insurrectionist on the brink of aketa
about to shred the Constitution it
doesn't matter that the video footage
showed that he was getting a private
tour around the capital by the police
doesn't matter that the only person
killed in political violence on January
6th was a trump supporter killed by a
trigger happy cop that none of that
matters the the story was already
written okay and any facts that don't
fit that narrative are going to be
twisted they're going to be Rewritten or
they're going to be discarded
and in the case of Sandra de o Conor she
doesn't fit the narrative that the first
woman on the court would be appointed by
a Conservative Republican that she
herself would be at least somewhat
conservative that she would not stand up
for all the big liberal causes it
doesn't fit so she's gone she's out and
the replacement is Ruth b Ginsburg and
that's that the reason I mention all of
this is not just to gripe or to defend
the sacred honor of Sandra de o Conor or
something it's to remind conservatives
we will never get the credit it's not
going to happen we're never going to get
the nice New York Times piece we're
never going to get the the beautiful PBS
special we're never going it's not going
to happen we're always going to be evil
we're always going to be idiots we're
always going to be knuckle dragging hit
larian figures who want to destroy our
country and kill everyone on Earth it's
that's always going to be the case in
fact if the libs are giving you the nice
New York Times article they are giving
you the PBS special they are giving you
the big parades then you're probably
doing something wrong if you are
receiving the plaits and the honors of
this world and the principalities and
powers and spiritual wickedness and high
places that govern this world you're
probably doing something wrong that
should worry you that should worry you a
hell of a lot more than being discarded
or being lied about or being slandered
or being lied okay it's a great honor
that no one is paying attention to
Sandra de o Conor's
death it is something that ought to
ought to be worrisome to the friends and
admirers of Ruth berer Ginsburg that she
is so so highly revered by a a rotten
very very corrupt political structure
that's the way it goes there is no
there's no neutrality here okay and as
far as the minations of this world go
the libs have the upper hand no doubt
about it now speaking of
death breaking news
story and that is it's not that it's not
that Norman Lear just died that story
happened a week ago two weeks ago that's
not the breaking news the breaking news
from E
entertainment is that Norman lear's
cause of death has been revealed I don't
know why this is kind of a weird article
it says Norman L's cause of death
revealed and then there's Jerry Springer
on there I don't that's kind of strange
but Norman Le great sitcom producer came
up with All in the Family The Jeffersons
Good Times all sorts of great sitcoms
from the 70s Norman Le's cause of death
revealed now before reading the article
I don't want to jump to conclusions I
think his cause of death might have had
something to do with being 101 years old
I'm pretty sure I don't think that I am
going
to open up this article read through it
and find out that the cause of death was
flipping his Corvette after shooting an
eightball I don't I'm not saying it
couldn't happen the man was prominent in
the 70s that was the sort of thing you
did then but I I don't expect that I
think it's probably because the guy with
was pretty much as old as you can
possibly be and that was the cause of
death was just being around a really
long time cuz then you die uh really
silly I maybe they're just posting these
articles because it's clickbait but it
shouldn't work as clickbait people
shouldn't click on this because everyone
knows the cause of
death and the cause of death actually I
did read the article the cause of death
is that his body just stopped because he
was old his heart and his lungs stopped
and that was it of
course why this matters
politically is that we are no longer
acquainted with death we don't see death
we're not around death very much anymore
and so whenever someone dies we view
that as an accident we view that as
something preventable there are all
sorts of Genius zillionaires in Silicon
Valley who are investing oodles and
oodles of money to cure death just like
the Pharaohs of old just like everyone
has every Elite and diluted person has
done for a very long time they view
death as some evil awful thing and
obstacle to be
overcome no one here Gets Out Alive okay
and in a way while death is a curse for
the Disobedience of our first parents in
the Garden of Eden it's also a way out
because you don't want to live forever
in a fallen world that would be a
terribly painful experience and we do
have the opportunity to live forever but
it's not in the way that the that
liberal utopians think it is it's not by
putting our brains in a vat or something
like that the way to do that is to uh
well accept our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ you know a traditional religion
and to uh to transcend this world that's
the way to do it we can't deal with that
now we don't like that idea we don't
like the we don't even like the idea of
death so we look away from it we don't
have funerals anymore we have
celebrations of life we don't have
three-day wakes anymore we don't have
wakes at all we don't want to look at
the body we don't and and when a 101y
old dies we say golly what got him what
got him I don't know the same thing
that's going to get you probably if
you're lucky the same thing that's going
to get you which is time now speaking of
life and death now is the time to go
check out pre-born right now go to
pre-born docomo this Christmas season is
rapidly approaching while you are
writing out your Christmas list remember
that we are now in the season of giving
and if you are not sure what to give I
will tell you give the gift of life
through our partnership with pre-born
pre-born is an organization that has
rescued over 270,000 babies from
abortion by offering free ultrasounds to
abortion-inducing woman hears the
ultrasound twice as likely not to abort
her child for just 28 bucks you can save
a life by sponsoring a mother's
ultrasound pre-born also supports
mothers by providing them with diapers
car seats counseling and more every day
preborn network of clinics rescues 200
babies as they compete head-to-head with
the abortion Giants now through a match
your tax deductible gift is doubled your
donation offers double the blessings and
that is double the chance at life for a
baby now is the time to put your year
end right offs to work have your
donation matched today by dialing pound
250 saying keyword baby that is pound
250 keyword baby or donate securely at
pre-born dcoms that is pre-worn docomo
Wes Christmas is only a few days away if
you are searching for the perfect gift
for your family your friends your
colleagues even yourself we got you
covered dailywire plus annual
subscriptions are 30% off that is one
year of unlimited access to adree
uncensored exclusive content from all
your favorite dailywire hosts for 30%
off along with ond demand access to
groundbreaking entertainment and
documentaries leading the charge in the
culture War trust me you don't want to
miss what we have coming in 2024 like Mr
burum the hilarious animated series with
a star studded voice cast featuring Adam
Cora Roseanne Bar Megan Kelly or varion
bre Cooper and more as well as the
highly anticipated release of the pen
Dragon cycle which will bring the
legendary story of King Arthur to life
like never before dailywire plus
memberships also unlock our new kids app
bent key at no extra charge enjoy over
20 titles and hundreds of episodes that
are kid-friendly and age appropriate yes
bent key is where you will be able to
watch Snow White and evil queen in 2024
best part is you'll be joining us in the
fight to take back and reshape the
culture this Christmas give the gift of
a daily wire plusus annual membership
for 30% off go to dailywire.com
subscribe and join
today now speaking of entertainment and
the media this is a great story I love
this I love this the New York times is
attacking
us for chip Chilla that's our most
popular kids show my little boy
sometimes he goes to bed and I says da
can I bring chip Chilla and he's got a
little stuffed animal you know he loves
chip
Chilla the fantasy of the fun TV dad in
the children series Bluey and its
conservative knockoff chip chill that's
how they describe they say we're
knocking off because we have a basic
children's show that's normal that was
like every children's show until 20
years ago uh they say it's a knockoff
boundlessly attentive fathers step into
a suage parental
anxieties so the New York times is
attacking not just chip Chilla but also
this show Bluey which I've never seen
but I guess it's I don't know it's
similar type of show it's just a show
that would would have been normal kids
content like all kids
content 20 30 40 years ago so they hate
it this is the New York Times on chip
chill they say I don't know how he keeps
house this is the daddy the doggy Daddy
I don't know how he keeps house works as
an archaeologist and serves as a
full-time prop artist to his daughters
but he does it all well only feigning
complaint he is not only a good father
he is a fantasy one crafted to appeal to
adults as much as to Children feel very
bad for this critic here for the New
York Times Amanda Hess because the
reason I mention the article is not not
just cuz they're going after chip Chilla
or not because of Bluey which I don't
know anything
about this
woman can't even
imagine a good father being
real the New York Times the
libs they can't even imagine the
possibility of a guy being a good
father part of this I'm not I'm not
getting into any psycho Babble with the
author or even the New York Times
editors but part of this I find is that
all liberalism ultimately comes down to
screw you
Dad 100% of the time 100% of the time
it's not even a personal Insight I
discovered that I heard it from a buddy
of mine Greg years ago he used saltier
language and I laughed and I thought wow
you're so right all every lib I
know to some
degree hates his dad everyone I don't
know it's weird but once you see it you
can't unsee
it and even if not your Earthly father I
think it's 100% of the time even with
their Earthly fathers certainly with
their Heavenly fathers they've got some
gripe against God the Father you know
this the cosmos the the create the way
that the cosmos was created how
everything works here they just but also
it just very basically they just hate
their dads they all have daddy issues
and it's very sad to me that in the year
of Our Lord 2023 the libs it's not even
that they say I I had a bad father and I
should have had a good father or it's
not even just that they're saying well
fatherhood needs to be tweaked a little
bit or there's some issues with the way
fathers are expected to be it's they
can't even
fathom a a
meticulous
attentive responsible fun loving father
they can't they say it's just a total
fantasy they go on as I watch the show
over my three-year-old son's shoulder I
wonder what Bandit says about the latent
desires of the parents queuing up the
show more than 100 episodes are
streaming on Disney plus with more
arriving in January after all when I
turn on Bluey I'm being very unbanded I
am not engaged in focused play that
follows my children's imagination where
it leads I'm cleaning my son is staring
at a
screen so the guilt that this person is
feeling
for allowing their children to watch TV
a
lot is leading them to attack the show
say it's unrealistic that parents would
actually take care of their kids parents
do it I'm I'm not knocking screen time
too we I think everybody does a little
bit of screen time every now and again
but believe it or not there was a time
when
parents did spend much more time with
their kids it was a lot easier when
women didn't have to work now women do
have to work it's not it's not that
women get to work now women have to work
in most economic
circumstances liberalism presents that
as a choice an active empowerment it's
not a choice for most people it's a
requirement of our current political
economy that was very intentionally
structured that way and so women they
have this illusion of choice but they
don't really have a choice they're
forced to go out and work for some
random guy who owns the widget Factory
and they have to labor in the widget
Factory so that they can make enough
money to bring home so their husband can
pay some other woman to raise their kids
and when they don't pay some other woman
to raise their kids and they don't send
them to daycare or state funded or
private they stick them in front of a TV
and they have the the TV rais their kids
and they feel bad about that naturally I
and it's not even just a personal
failing it's a it's a social failing
it's a political failing that we now
have a political economy that almost
forces you to do that but that tension
that that feeling of guilt is what is
impelling very clearly she's explaining
it here it's impelling some of her anger
some of her
or dissatisfaction with the show she
goes on it's typical in children's
stories for Parental figures to be
obscured or even absent especially the
mothers Disney movies I grew up on
Little Mermaid Lion King featured
authoritarian fathers who following the
untimely deaths of their wives ruled
their children from a distance while
Outsourcing their child care to a crab
or a
bird I don't know that that's exactly
how I would describe the Lion King that
seems a little a little off but anyway
my son's favorite show is is not Bluey
but Mickey Mouse Clubhouse in which
Mickey's parentage is irrelevant he's a
god-like figure who answers to no one
that is a fantasy for children total
parental obsolescence well no it's a
fantasy for your your
children that's the difference here this
New York Times writer I don't know where
this person
lives I guess New York I should assume
but who knows big
newspaper she is ex she has inculcated
certain values in her children we all do
inevitably that's that's what education
is that's what parenting is and so what
the liberals do is they inculcate
liberal values and the liberal value is
is one of not the U Unity of the
generations not of respecting one's
elders and caring for one's young and
and recognizing an an unbroken thread
between the generations that gives us a
respect and a reverence and a care for
the the traditions and the institutions
that we've inherited and a and a desire
a charitable desire to pass those on to
Future Generations it it gives one the
the desire to break free of all of that
to view the past as as baggage as as a
burden as oppression to view the future
as something that does not deserve our
care or our attention it's not our
responsibility to break free of all the
bonds the bonds of politics which is
viewed as oppression the bonds of family
also viewed as oppression the bonds of
morality also it's all viewed as
oppression even the bonds of biology now
in this case where where people are told
to break free of their very bodies so
that if their body
uh shows their identity to be one thing
they will break free of that they'll say
damn my body who cares I'm going to be
something totally different that that's
a liberal view the The View that the
little child that the individual should
be God that's the liberal view that's
not good not the kind of thing you want
to inculcate in your
kid but the New York Times writer the
New York Times editors can't imagine
that in the conservative parts of the
country in the conservative households
that's not the child's fantasy CU
children's fantasies are they don't just
pop out of the air okay they they
develop as the children are educated
children are sponges and desire is
mimetic so the way that we human beings
come to desire something is not not just
uh written into the code of our DNA
necessarily and it's not just because an
object is intrinsically desirable it's
mimetic we observe the desires of those
around us especially those closest to us
and those we respect like our parents
and we emulate those very
desires clearest example of this is a
Rolex watch no one really desires a
Rolex watch because it's a they know all
that much about horology no one really
desires a Rolex watch some people like
the way it looks some people like the
history of it some people like but the
biggest driver for why people desire
Rolex watches is because other people
desire
them the the reason that you covet your
neighbor's wife is not because she's the
hottest chick around it's because she's
your neighbor's wife that's that in fact
that's why coveting that's why mimetic
desire is is is included multiple times
in the Ten Commandments because that's
so intrinsic to human nature and human
desire and so this woman seems
completely unaware oblivious that she
has cultivated certain Desires in her
kid and that's the desire to be a God
that's the desire to be totally free of
all bonds free of parents that's it's
not the desire that conservatives
cultivate in their kids what
conservatives cultivate in their kids is
I think a much healthier desire which is
to love your family love your community
respect your parents be happy when your
dad stays home and plays around with you
she goes on I wonder if one of the
upsides of Bluey from a parents
perspective is that it works to absolve
our guilt over screen time if we feel
bad for ignoring or subduing our
children there we go there's a little
bit of self-awareness creeping in yeah
yeah I wonder if blue at least offers a
simulation of boundless parental
attention right you yes you're you're
becoming self-aware New York Times lady
and you're recognizing that that's a
good thing to have your parents pay a
lot of attention to you and it would be
nice if if parents did that out of
choice or even were able to do that and
our political economy were not such that
you had to go to the widget Factory all
day yeah you're right why do you have
that guilt why do you have that guilt
because
it's by enacting liberalism you are
denying things that are that we know
naturally to be
good the moms in blue this is the final
paragraph I'll mention it's a long
article it's worth reading the moms in
blue and Chip Chilla Chile and Chin
don't get the classic Disney movie
treatment they're allowed to live they
get to join in the fun too though Chile
is more levelheaded than her husband and
chinny is Stern both mothers are granted
supporting roles in their children's
imaginative worlds though they are
somewhat sidelined by their plots often
because of their work outside and within
the home in chip Chilla this is the this
is the money line in chip Chilla chinny
is the one stuck holding the laundry
basket and that is why the New York
Times ladies of the world the Liberals
of the
world won't be able to resolve the
tension they're feeling
because they're just like their little
kids demanding to be Gods they're just
like their little kids demanding to be
totally free of all natural constraint
and all natural
inclinations is they resent that the
woman might do the
laundry and the man might go to work
outside of the home everybody works they
they resent that they resent that men
and women are
different but someone's going to have to
go work outside the home so if you deny
that men and women are
different then you're both going to go
to work outside the home and if you both
go to work outside the home then you're
just not going to get to spend as much
time with your
kids and that's a sad
fact these are the people who who want
this the the New York Times these are
the people who are driving this there
are so many people I know I mean I think
it probably most people I know the woman
Works outside the home often not by
choice those are the people that I feel
the sorest for here those are the true
victims of all of this because we now
have and we've had it for almost a
hundred years now a political
economy that that forces this situation
and that that makes it into an
unimaginable fantasy that you would get
to spend a lot of time with your parents
especially with your mother would you
imagine you imagine back in the old day
those old awful days when your mother
was stuck holding the laundry basket and
everyone was really happy and that story
is actually so attractive that two two
shows are about that and they happen to
be two of the most popular children's
shows
around amazing not a good look these
days when you want to look good you got
to check out Jus cell right now go to
genucell.com there's a lot to be
stressed about during this Christmas
season stress and lack of sleep can
easily cause those pesky under eye bags
the good news is you never have to worry
about that again when you have Jus cell
skincare from now until Christmas
genell's most popular package has a
special discount just for our listeners
at genucell.com
kwes treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute best skincare in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness even a sagging
jawline will disappear right before your
eyes with genus cell's most popular
collection genus cell promises immediate
effects you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed or your money
back J youell made Christmas come early
this year they sent down a ton of
products for the whole office everyone
is raving about the under eye cream this
works wonders plus included in every
most popular package is your free
hyaluronic acid serum for skin hydration
and restoration you deserve to look and
feel good this Christmas season you know
I love this company I love the founder
cop a Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream uses absolutely the best
ingredients out out there an amazing
discount on your first order because
you're going to be a customer for a very
long time go to Jus cell.com
kwes get this great Christmas discount
every order instantly upgraded to
express free shipping today jus.com
noes my favorite comment yesterday comes
from Bryce
Gladwin who says you're wrong Michael
when you say people of all kinds are
going to read this document no no one is
going to read this document and
everyone's going to assume it agrees
with them you make a great point talking
about the document from the Vatican
yesterday that would seem to permit some
kind of blessings for samesex couples
with caveats and blah blah blah you can
hear my talk about it yesterday you're
right no one's going to read that
document because no one reads documents
anymore and everyone just assumes that
it agrees with them so true now speaking
of what your kids are
learning the president of
Harvard the baguer president of Harvard
is under Fire again for more plagiarism
it started out because as Chris rufo the
great Chris rufo conservative journalist
and think tank scholar and Aaron sarian
another conservative journalist I don't
even know if he's conservative he's
certainly
anti-left they
both uncovered instances of plagiarism
from the president of Harvard this was
after the president of Harvard showed up
with the president of Penn
and suggested that calling for genocide
against the Jews you know might be okay
okay if we just do it within the right
context and so after that hearing the
pen lady was instantly fired and she was
fired because she's a white lady so it's
easy to fire her because she's a dirty
rotten Karen and no one likes Karens so
get rid of the white ladies but claudian
gay president of Harvard who said the
exact same thing as the president of
Penn she was allowed to keep her job
because she's a black lady and black
ladies can do no wrong and they can't be
fired or you're a racist if you even
suggest that they should be but
there was a difference
between gay and the pen lady even beyond
their skin color that being that the pen
lady seems to have had a perfectly fine
academic career and the Harvard lady
Claudine gay is a
plagiarist she was caught plagiarizing
her doctoral
dissertation and then once we started
pulling on that thread a little we saw
more instances of plagiarism and more
instances now there's 40 instances of
plagiarism and plagiarism might not seem
like the worst crime in the world
in Academia it is the single worst thing
you can do you could go walk into a
classroom shoot the professor in the
head that is a less serious academic
crime than plagiarism that it might be
the singular academic
crime totally guts scholarly
credibility and this woman was found to
have stolen actually from a friend of
mine from Carol Swain Professor Carol
Swain wonderful political scientist has
been on this show and other shows that
I've hosted claudian gay the the head of
Harvard stole from her and stole from a
lot of other Scholars well
now this is amazing Chris Chris rufo
found this
one apparently claudian gay plagiarized
the acknowledgements section of one of
her
books the acknowledgements I understand
you plagiarize scholarship because
you're just not that good a scholar you
don't do your own research you don't
you're just not that you're just not
that good a writer you're not that good
a researcher you're not that good a
scholar
okay you should at least be able to
write the thank you note at the end of
the book don't you think I don't that's
not very hard but no they plagiarized
that as
well
Claudine
gay uh I'm also grateful to Gary as a
methodologist he reminded me the of the
importance of getting the data and
getting the data right and following
where they lead without fear or favor as
an adviser he gave me the attention and
the opportunities I needed to do my best
work now that's from claudi and gay
taking charge black electoral success
and redefinition of American politics
here is an earlier piece from a year
this is one year earlier from Jennifer
Hawk's child facing up to the American
dream who writes Sandy jenss showed me
the importance of getting the data right
and of following where they lead without
fear or
favor it's just a direct quote there's
more there's more too I wow you can't
can't make that stuff
up how does Harvard go on here how does
Claudine gay go on here a remedial
seventh grader would not have stolen
this
clumsily and yet here we are a lot of
people including Chris calling for
claudian gay to resign as president of
Harvard I don't want her to resign I
don't want claudian gay to resign as
president of Harvard for the same reason
that I don't want Bob Mendez to resign
as the New Jersey
senator I want to drag this
out every second that these people
remain in their
offices I'm not going to say that they
degrade their respective institutions
Harvard University and the Democratic
party I'm not going to say that they
degrade them they don't the the
institutions are already
degraded what happens is every second
that gay and Mendez stay in their
respective offices they further expose
to more and more people how degraded
their respective institutions have
already become and I really like that
every second that Bob Mendez remains in
office the likelihood that a republican
replaces him in New Jersey increases by
3% likewise every second that claudian
gay Remains the president of Harvard a a
plagiarist a notorious plagiarist if if
a if a
freshman
committed one
iota 140th of the plagiarism that Claud
anday has has committed over her career
that student would be expelled from
Harvard probably would not be admitted
to another college would just be done
with college it's that serious an
infraction every second that CL Claud
and gay remains in Office Harvard looks
more and more ridiculous more and more
students will say why would I go there
now you might say well go there because
Harvard still has some credibility might
kchen the DOR at Goldman's a or
something yeah for now sure does it has
some Prestige though frankly if you see
this kind of Scandal you see Harvard
becoming the laughing stock of the
academic world even if you do want to go
to those name brand schools you're
probably more likely to go to Yale
you're probably more likely to go to
Princeton you're probably more likely to
go to Stanford you're probably more
likely to go to I don't know some other
really brand name school and Harvard
will be hit and Harvard should be hit
Harvard
should be destroyed as a prestigious
institution Harvard denda EST to quote
some ancient Romans okay the
universities the elite universities
especially are the epicenter of the
left's power they are how the left the
radical left took control over the last
years the more they get hit the more
ridiculous they look the better now
speaking of
scholarship I'm going to tease a little
story
here not going to totally get into it
you know me I'm a tease there is a
peer-reviewed scientific study was
published on
Wednesday uh last Wednesday I suppose in
the public library of Sciences Journal
plos and it investigated greenhouse gas
emissions of methane and nitrous oxide
in human breath and it
concluded that one of the significant
drivers of global warming climate
change is your
breathing you you when you breathe when
you do the thing that is most basic to
sustain your life you're destroying the
world the
inference I suppose the conclusion that
we have to draw from this is that if you
want to save the world you have to you
have to stop breathing you have to we
need to we need to get rid of all the
humans and this was all this was always
the way that this global warming cult
was going to end this global warming
suicide cult was always going to end
with this study we'll get to it tomorrow
today however is what Wednesday the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member use code
nolles KW so check out for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
o